cherry qu'est-ce que l'amitié pour vous
c'est important car aujourd'hui l'amitié
je voudrais qu'on me dise et l'amitié et
l'amour qu'est ce que c'est que pour
vous parce que la frontière est un film
si la frontière est un film quoi banon
quand même
je comprends pas ce que vous dites est
alors on s'amusait avant il ya une
grande et non pour moi c'est un film
regardez daniel c'est la zizanie mais
pourtant avoir échoué à deux mais c'est
vrai mais c'est pas ça mais pourquoi
lancer sans doute doit
toujours à sa demande jean marais je
vais demander à déjà il géraldine
maillet qui est pour moi
la lancé rudy de la bande après benhaim
bien sûr après qu'il
ait juste devant rien
pour moi c'est donner quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas à quelqu'un qui n'en veut
pas ou là qu'on est bien
c'est johnny est l'amour c'est donner
quelque chose qu'on n'a pas à quelqu'un
qui n'en veut pas vous échappe
on peut pas on peut pas parler de
l'amour en fait on le vit on le huawei
voilà on le sent on le ressent peut pas
le chercher une quête ça vous tombe
dessus comme la foudre c'est
indéfinissable et aux concepteurs chien
qu'on pressent que vous avez définition
de l'amitié valérie benaïm
match je suis d'accord avec vous ses
nièces et bien gagné vous quand vous
dites que vous êtes revenez amiens pas
du tout pas du tout je dis ça y est tu
as raison je suis pas digne et ailleurs
comprendront par les sorties
on est où là et quand on voit plus ça
sert il oui elle a haussé de la tête il
aurait dû sortir aussi
pour l'instant ça va mais elle échoue
sous surveillance gilles verdez qu'est
ce que c'est alors l'amitié l'amour
c'est un petit peu vous et fatou on sait
pas où vous en êtes
bah ça commence bien sinon c'est très
bien où on en est l'amitié pour moi
d'abord ses hommes comme je vous le dis
franchement il ne pourrait pas les avoir
d'amitié avec une femme non alors delphi
pour reconstituer le fil des mois on
peut pas être amis ah non c'est
impossible je vous je comprend
ce qu'on boit surtout du côté delphine
ça ne peut pas durer elle a tiré par
mois comment animaux sur un free
wheels bador mon amitié hommes femmes
sinon nous on peut être à venir
est
d'ailleurs nominé il y aura toujours une
petite ambiguïté
sur une île déserte après quelques
années quoi nous deux oui sur une île
déserte après quelques années qu'est-ce
qui se passerait si quand même n'aurait
pas fait à l'ambiguïté est
ce que l'ambiguïté restaurer ou est ce
qu'elle sera pas de fête à troquer qui
si on était ensemble sur une idée des
années qu'on me donnait de temps
et vous c'est décidé vous savez bien
vous détendre à quai
peut-être pas si longtemps que ça ouais
bah ouais je pense dit moi moi alors je
vous dire au bout de deux jours j'épouse
daniel
tu couches avec au bout non je dis je
c'est fou hein c'est moi son sens hier
et l'amour je vous ai manqué
d'amour pour moi je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec les filles c'est très
concret c'est quand on court après la
personne
précipite vers l on ne la laisse pas
échapper dès qu'elle est là on tourne
autour on la voit
la bouche tour elle attendait choléra
sont légaux salut c'est un enfer alors
lycéens ont fait un boom mais c'est quoi
non c'est tout l'inversé à dire que
l'amour c'est un plus un égale deux ans
plus jeune au tessin
la fusion séparera plus un gars c'est
pas se diluer l'un dans l'orne au
contraire a ajouté également que c'est
que ces conneries
on apprend des trucs de fou mais c'est
quand même là et puis élu dans l'amitié
c'est connaître l'autre complètement et
les mais malgré tout c'est à dire en
connaissance de cause
pour défaut il est vrai que le plaignant
tout est né j'ai battu avec un passionné
si vous mais on a la chance d'avoir
quelqu'un qui peut nous servir des
cocktails dans cette émission
le gars on dirait qu'il fait pas du tout
partie de l'émission
mais garde tout à l'heure je regardais
dire yako maths c'est l'impression
qu'elle stoppait tu me mets
virgin mojito
la diva du tass
c'est très beau sarr si vous avez acheté
bien longtemps
jeanny marc auquel adam riess et linda
kent bien sûr on en voit se rabat à
laval
merci oui moi j'ai une définition très
philosophique de l'amitié en fait c'est
une personne à qui je ne peux pas ken tu
ne veux pas cannes avec moi
et l'amour c'est quelqu'un qui me fait
souffrir
je souffre beaucoup en amour
très bien
alors la vitesse est simple c'est ce qui
vous reste quand on a tout perdu voilà
c'est fini alors c'est ce qu'on en est
un bah oui pas plus d'amis m'insérer
bêtement reste vous merci
si je peux me permettre comptez pas trop
tu dans
[Rires]
l'amour c'est quand tout perdre n'a plus
d'importance au lot
alors déjà gagne elle est amoureuse mais
voilà daniela c'est un truc de là je
vais rien faire avec moi je suis le
turini le désert vous là mais ne riez
lui ben oui je
suis avec vous sur une île amènera tout
alla zodiac
a arrêté daniel o daniel moi j'irai avec
vous sur une île déserte
franchement oui oui oui mais ça me
dérangerait pas du tout allez-y quoi
allez on est pas on n'est pas on n'est
pas aux pièces
vous à la mine san jose un ça va
alors ça va très bien c'est vrai que ben
et où j'ai bien tenu là j'ai pas de
débattre des pressions menaces même
réponse chez les gens du droit
j'aimerais quand même un petit mais
d'aucuns
[Rires]
préfèrent algo vous courrez dans la
sixième
[Rires]
l'amitié c'est simple c'est celui qui
est capable de te dire les choses en
face même quand ça va un connard
ces cas là c'est ça pour moi faut dire
des choses dans toute circonstance
l'amour c'est tu es en bagnole à 200km
arrête à plus de freins tu fais
n'importe quoi tu sais plus où tu es tu
sais plus où tu vas les plus grands de
ce monde sont n'importe quoi par amour
ou par amour même un mec comme vous peut
avoir 16 ans par amour par amour tu as
16 ans tu redeviens un petit garçon sait
capable de faire tout et n'importe quoi
par un mois comme moi non mais vous
voulez puissant parce que j'ai des
puissants jésus même un mec sans les
puissants même un mec qui gère science
est un exemple depuis deux et il
maîtrise tout de a à z quand il tombe
amoureux ah ouais il fait n'importe quoi
et c'est bien pour ça que moi d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que je porte et je
fais n'importe quoi et c'est bien pour
ça que l'amour n'a pas d'âge ses mots ce
qu'ils disent est très ses mots ce qui
vient à lui sans regret elle sait
combien c'est beaucoup parce que c'est
si les deux plus conclut dit les miens
[Applaudissements]
bonne équipe on est de plus
un compliment dacquois ont la demande à
daniel non
j'ai fait un peu de jeu mais trinh
l'amitié c'est l'amour à la verticale et
l'amour c'est l'amitié à l'horizontale
c'est ma thérapie
[Rires]
pour moi l'amitié c'est une personne à
qui on peut parler sans filtre voilà
qu'on a pas admettre de filtre on peut
se montrer tel qu'on est comme maxwell
c'est une personne avec laquelle on sent
l'amour non non la pitié sur une
personne avec laquelle le silence n'est
pas gênant quand c'est vraiment un ami
on peut être dans le silence on a besoin
de parler parce qu'à faire des blancs et
c'est là qu'on voit que la à wemmel à la
raison un ami c'est ça ouais moi je vois
qu'il y avait quelqu'un à qui je suis
ami je peux me parler rester sur lui
parler pendant une semaine
d'écart c'est comme ça
merci moi comme
ça non mais je perdis kof qui sera dans
le prime tout à l'heure à ne pas manquer
le grand retour mais nicolas pernoud qui
reviendra des ténèbres
pour nous et l'amour non mais quand la
personne à côté voilà quand la personne
et aux côtés un ami nations unies par
les forces et accrochez-vous le
considérer comme un ami lui non mais
dillon guillaume considéré comme un ami
jadis
alors jadis pour nous regardons français
ça veut dire hier soir
alors oui jadis c'est un m a dit qu en
vérité je pense que c'est moi qui le
plus votre ami maintenant enfin on a eu
un passage difficile après punta cana
faucon retisser des liens voilà se sont
hissés gâchez pas vers l'autre pour
autistes et derrière bastia alors pas du
tout à ça c'est pas moi qui décide non
mais hier elle a fait un pas vers moi
vous êtes
fière elle en a parlé ça m'a touché ça
devrait toucher ça m'a touché oui ça m'a
touché définit alors je voulais vous en
parlait déjà à la base en or et puis je
me suis dit je savais pas et puis au
final je les fais comme ça en direct
avec mon coeur et sebo delphi je vous
êtes vous arrivé à lui parler en off ben
oui pourquoi tu la vois
parler en off ah oui ce mois-ci par
téléphone
ça va toi ça va tout le temps
donc l'amour et donc l'amour pour moi ça
ça réunit et l'amitié et l'attirance et
la connexion etc la personne avec qui on
a envie de tout faire donc un amour
c'est aussi un ami et c'est un amant et
c'est tout en même temps c'est un tout
ces boîtes
[Rires]
mais bravo des films c'est beau ce que
tu as dit c'est à dire j'adhère allez
vous alors bon c'est très honnête
l'amitié c'est en cas de besoin
quelqu'un qui peut te donner un organe
qui en double poumon raincourt
tiens pas têtu mais hama a pour mot et
de kujaa c'est pas bien merci tu
trouvais ça normal un cadeau merci au
risque de choquer très bientôt si
l'amour c'est vivre avec quelqu'un qui
est plus riche que ce soit
et nous fait que les emmerdes c'est fou
ce à quoi la mort ça pour toi moi je
vais vous dire ce que c'est mal mais ce
soir là me thibault - ouais c'est
quelqu'un qui ne demandent jamais
d'argent
sinon bah je suis ton pote alors oui
c'est vrai je sais rien moi pas trop
et l'amour c'est quoi alors l'amour
c'est quelqu'un l'argent
qui vous rend là j'ai compris quand on
prend l'argent qui te rend là j'ai
compris que ça va pour la barre
sam hamad el fille delphine je la bois
elle elle va mieux mais là je suis
soulagée j'ai un point - vous étiez pas
bien mais j'étais jeune c'était quoi la
brousse parce que la témoin tient à
brouilla étaient partis en vadrouille en
avant les vacances
j'aimerais qu'on revienne là-dessus
parce que je croise évoquant un film
était était alité et des claviers elle
était
recroquevillé comme années comme un
petit coq les pêcheurs moyens pas non
non je vous jure c'est vrai n'était pas
bien les dream crosby
depuis que on s'est reparlé delphine
is back je suis sensible c'est vrai
parce que je suis sensible comme vous je
pense et vous savez pas en vrai j'ai pas
pu vous dire pourquoi j'ai dû partir en
urgence je vous le dirai un jour non
mais je vous de ça je vous le dirai
après
est ce que roger est en train de
préparer le non non je regarde un ami
doit aussi comprendre quand est-ce que
c'est vital pour une personne et c'est
pour ça que j'ai demandé à personne je
suis parti j'ai pas dit quand je
rentrais j'en ai vraiment besoin et donc
la mitis aussi de comprendre sa non
gelée compris des films
facilement
[Rires]
quoi mais par exemple si si c'est vital
pour nous de ne rien
dire moi aussi c'est vital pour moi j'ai
un besoin vital de virer des gens
peut pas vraiment aller ici avec l'oeil
ça va ça va remplir également mon besoin
dans mes delphine est ce qu'on peut
savoir qu'est-ce qui sait pas si c'est
quoi vous deviez pas non mais vous avez
besoin de vous retrouver je crois oui
non mais au-delà de ça maintenant il y
avait encore vraiment d'autres choses
qui sont qui était beaucoup plus grave
mais il ya vital est vitale et moi
vraiment c'était pas un ce n'était pas
un caprice et vous savez que je suis
sérieuse travailleuse et relativement
scolaire ou si je suis parti c'est que
j'en avais besoin donc c'est très cool
que que la région est vitale
et ma mère tout va bien